in 30 years I will be younger than today
not older I will be younger so I yeah
because we're going to have rejuvenation
technique and these experiments are
beginning right now I am Nicolas be with
reason and today we are talking with
Jose Cordero he is a founding faculty
member of singularity University Jose
thanks for talking I pleasure to be here
to talk about the future all right well
let's talk about the future of two
things one about singularity University
and then also about Venezuela your your
home country singularity University is a
place that is dedicated to exploring and
analyzing and coming up with what the
future looks like especially in terms of
kind of life enhancement human life
enhancement longevity life extension
what's the most what are the things that
you're most interested about right now
well things are accelerating we really
live in exponential times and medicine
is being radically transformed there is
a disruption and we are going to be
living longer lives healthier lives a
probably indefinite life spans very soon
if I'm trying to find very soon well we
talk at the latest by 2045 Ray Kurzweil
who is the chairman of the finger Larry
two University he says that a he plans
to become immortal by 2000 2045 and I
believe in that as well
in fact I do not plan to die even more
interesting in 30 years
I will be younger than today not older I
will be younger
swine yeah because we are going to have
rejuvenation techniques and these
experiments are beginning right now
there are patients who are being
rejuvenated with experimental treatments
what are some of those treatments and
how do we know that they will work
either immediately or in the long term
well one of the things that they are
being experimented with is increasing
the telomeres at the end of the
chromosomes actually this is what cancer
does cancer cells are biologically
inmortal they do not age so scientists
are trying to understand why cancer has
discovered how not to age so that we can
apply that to the rest of the body this
is one of the most interesting things
that are being experimented and there is
already one human patient that has
undergoing this kind of treatment for
over one year and her cells actually are
becoming younger according to the length
of the telomeres they are really growing
so they are becoming longer which means
that she is younger today while from a
policy angle what are the regulatory
issues that most intersect and block
this kind of research or this kind of
advancement well this is an excellent
question because this experimental
treatment cannot be done in the USA
right now because it is illegal in order
to do an experimental treatment even in
yourself with your own money you need
approvals so this person that is
undergoing this treatment leaves parish
who lives in Oregon estate she actually
had to fly to South America I helped her
also to find some doctors that could
help to start this treatment and even
though she paid and she did it on
herself that was not legal in the USA so
she had to go to another country I think
this is horrible in the USA the medical
industry is highly regulated and you
cannot try an experiment on yourself and
that is a tragedy I think how do you
guard against the negative singularity
so you know because the singularity can
be great and that's kind of where a
network of machines and of human mind
starts multiplying exponentially and
change becomes almost instantaneous and
in a positive direction do you worry at
all about negative outcomes from from
this type of exponential growth and
advancement in technology and
capabilities I am very optimistic in
general but I realized that there are
always negative outcomes and we have to
be prepared for those but I am not
worried about artificial intelligence in
fact how can you be worried about
becoming more intelligent you will be
able to know more to do more things to
be more intelligent so the problem is
not artificial intelligence the problem
is human stupidity and sadly human
stupidity is very natural so what we
need to do is to become more intelligent
to enhance our intelligence and
artificial intelligence will help us do
that Elon Musk recently you know the
impresario or entrepreneur behind tests
learn a variety of other paypal a
variety of things recently came out and
talked about having a kind of preemption
against certain types of artificial
intelligence do you think he's is he
getting nervous about the future well uh
maybe a little bit but he has other
plans as well you know he talks about
colonizing Mars maybe he wants to get
people is heard here on planet earth so
that we all go to Mars on the other hand
he he just started a new company called
neural link to link our brains our
neurons to the cloud so he's investing
himself in artificial intelligence so I
guess he's not too worried also he's a
personal friend of a Larry Page and
Sergey Brin who are betting everything
on artificial intelligence so I think
Google knows also what they are doing
though many people are opposed to the
idea of immortality not and this is an
able question of when or whether it will
become operational but you know they're
just against it because they say it's
unnatural what what is your response to
people who say we shouldn't try to
extend our lives or enhance our
capabilities
well average life is planned on about
2,000 years ago was 20 years you know
then in the 19th century we hit 40 years
today we are in 80 years so this is
increasing very fast and we are living
longer healthier lives so I think this
is what humans do we want to live better
we want to improve the world improve our
human condition so I think this is our
nature to live in a better time with
better lives so I think it's very
natural what is not natural is to want
to die at age 20 so you are venezuelan
venezuela it seems to be in the endgame
of a horrible catastrophe a completely
man-made catastrophe what is your sense
of how events are playing out in
venezuela as i mentioned before i am
very afraid of a human stupidity you
know we are very stupid humans are very
stupid we need to be more intelligent
therefore we need to get rid of these
horrible stupid governments and
and enhance them actually maybe we could
have a robot president who could be more
intelligent but talking about the
situation in Venezuela right now it
really is a tragedy the country has gone
back in time about a century people are
poorer there is no food there are no
medicines and there is a criminal regime
that is dealing in drugs and that is the
problem this is a narco general regime
they would not leave power because all
of those generals who are so corrupt
they know that once they get out of
power they will end up in jail the Drug
Enforcement Agency has ordered to
capture seven generals the vice
president of Venezuela and the Minister
of Defense
so they subtly have no way out any more
is there a way for this to end with less
bloodshed and less suffering well I wish
but then some of the military would have
to revolt against the generals who
control their drug dealings so it is
going to be very difficult very
difficult situation well we'll leave it
there we've been talking with Jose
Cordero he's a founding faculty member
of singularity University and Venezuelan
nado thanks for talking to us
a pleasure today for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]